well a new poll just came out that has
Joe Biden at the head of the Democratic
primary pack which isn't surprising but
Hillary Clinton is just about tied with
him she's ahead of everybody except
Biden who who she's almost tied with and
let me say if I could and I'm being
honest here I don't like to admit this
but I think I can speak for all of the
card-carrying members of the American
right of which of course I am a part of
that group but I speak for all of them
when I say that I am absolutely
terrified of a Hillary Clinton candidacy
it scares me so much
so please Hillary do not run I beg you
please don't run if you ran Hillary you
know you would just cruise to victory
and it wouldn't be fair it would not be
fair to do that to run for a third time
so we all come together all of us
conservatives and we join our hands and
our voices and we plead with you have
some mercy on us don't run for a third
time you are the one contender we fear
you are so dynamic so formidable such a
powerful force and personality and so
electric people are just and magnetic
you know people are drawn to you as we
saw the first two times you went I mean
really I think if you did run we would
we would throw up our hands and say no
point in having election now there's no
real it let's just I mean the why even
do it what's the point of go about why
waste our time doing the whole election
thing in fact I was talking to a friend
of mine recently we were we were we were
out at a bar at a kind of a right-wing
bar everyone had assault rifles
you know strapped to their backs and and
we were all wearing NRA hats and you
know like we do were just hanging out
and and he goes whew thank God Hilary
isn't running that lady is unbeatable
and I said I agree she's unbeatable but
I think she still might run and then he
started crying I'm not making this he
started crying when he was think
everyone in the bar everyone started
crying
think about what would happen if Hillary
couldn't ran for president this is how
it always go he goes you say the name
Hillary
to any conservative and they start
trembling with fear as tears well up in
their eyes and really Hillary with all
this stuff about Epstein in the news and
everything your husband being being
being such a good friend of his I think
that would be a huge help on the
campaign trail trail as well because it
gives you such a great insight into the
issue you know you could really talk
from experience about all the times your
husband rode on you know on Epstein's
private plane or went to his write
mansions and all that stuff it kind of
gives you this insight that no one else
has which i think is also a great asset
so the point is please don't run
i I promise you that is the last thing
we want then I guess which I just have
to move on because I can't even I can't
even think about this anymore because it
just disturbs me so much alright there's
much else to talk about today but before
we do that I need to tell you about
paint your life calm we just had our we
just had our painting sent to us and
it's absolutely beautiful and I have to
say I was I was really impressed not
just with the final result which is
which is gorgeous that's that's
spectacular but the whole process was
great it's very easy to navigate and the
folks over at paint your life are very
helpful and responsive through the whole
process because they they take great
pride in your painting as well and they
want you to love it and they're gonna
make sure you do so how it works is that
you send them a photo of your children
yourself family member a special place a
pet whatever you want and they'll make
you a gorgeous painting at a price that
you can afford this is a true painting
it's done by hand this is not some
computer graphic thing done by hand by a
world-class artist and it created from a
favorite photo that you send to them and
it's just the difference between a
photograph and a painting a painting
just bring something out of that photo
brings it extra character that's kind of
hard to describe or grasp you just have
to see it for yourself I think this is
great to do you know just for yourself
you could do it as a gift for yourself
for your home for your family or
obviously it makes a great gift as we
get into the holidays birthday gifts
wedding anniversary it's great for all
of that and there's no risk because if
you don't love the painting you don't
love the final painting you get your
money refunded but you will love it
trust me and right now as a limited
offer you can get 30% off your painting
30% off
painting right now you're not gonna get
a deal like this for very long so you
want to go right now it's free shipping
as well to get this special offer you
want to text Matt to 64,000 that's Matt
to 64,000 ma TT to six four zero zero
zero okay I want to start with this just
because it annoys me
the Boston Globe ran an article on
Friday complaining about Facebook which
is great because we've only seen about
10,000 of those kinds of articles in the
last month so in case you didn't get the
point yet the Boston Globe was there to
clarify things and talk about how
Facebook is terrible and evil and and
and all of that during the article they
decide to take a shot at the Daily wire
which also is not a unique thing either
but here's what the article says quoting
now in response we saw him
Zuckerberg launched a repurposed news
section that sets up partnerships
between the networks and wide in a wide
range of publishers and then in
parentheses including white supremacist
adjacent alt-right outposts like The
Daily wire yes white supremacists
adjacent alright output post those are
the two ways they describe the daily
wire now I have a couple of questions
here first of all what the hell is white
supremacists adjacent what does that
even mean white supremacists adjacent
well I'll tell you what it means it
means that they really wanted to just
come out and call us white supremacist
that's what they really wanted to do but
they realize that they couldn't because
Ben Shapiro is an Orthodox Jew and
calling an Orthodox Jew a white
supremacist is a bridge that they love
to cross but they know they really can't
I mean the media has crossed that bridge
many times before they've many times but
they end up getting blasted for it from
all directions because it's not only
stupid and wrong but it's grotesque so
instead they decide to pull their punch
a little bit on this one and they say
white supremacists adjacent they take
the coward's way out and this way they
can say oh no we didn't call you whites
premises we just said that you're white
supremacists adjacent is all sure okay
Boston Globe so this article was written
by a guy named Michael and/or Broder and
what I would say about Michael and or
Broder is well I would never call him a
stupid lying disgraceful smear merchant
I would never say that um I just
wouldn't it wouldn't be right it would
be very Christian of me so no he's not a
stupid line disgraceful smear merchant
he's just stupid lying disgraceful
disgraceful smear merchant adjacent you
see he's adjacent to that he hangs out
in the vicinity of being a lying [ __ ]
I'm not saying that he is no no I I
wouldn't ever say that I'm saying that
he's he just you know lie morons are
right here and he's kind of walking
alongside them adjacent you see and they
they like go to the same school and a
lot of times they end up wearing the
same shirts accidentally and they hang
out after class you know but I'm not
saying he's a lying [ __ ] he's just he's
always so adjacent very much adjacent
with that group is what I'm trying to
say and then there's the next part which
is calling us an alt right outpost now
this is great of course because there is
no conservative site on the entire
internet that the alt-right hates more
than the daily wire and if you don't
believe me you could just ask them or go
to one of their go to one of their
corners one of their dark and and and
grimy corners of the Internet and see
what they have to say about the daily
wire and the people who work for it and
there's also no person in the media
who's been targeted by the alright more
than that ben shapiro the rest of also
the rest of us have also gotten it not
not quite as bad as he has but but still
we've we've we've gotten our share of
that treatment the whole right has gone
after me many times i spent like three
days on this show a few months ago
screaming about one of them which was
probably not a great use of my time or
yours but the point is you know we're
not exact
we on friendly terms and calling the
daily wire of all web sites all right
that's like well it's like calling an
Orthodox Jew white supremacist or excuse
me white supremacist adjacent but this
is the way it always goes this is the
tactic just throw a label at your
opponent's right if you don't like
someone if you don't agree with them
label them doesn't matter if the label
is true doesn't matter if it makes sense
doesn't matter if it's coherent that
doesn't have to be any of those things
just all you need is the label and the
problem with this strategy one of the
many problems aside from the fact that
it's dishonest and unethical and
cowardly and all of that one of the
other significant problems is that what
happens is the labels rapidly lose their
meaning now a term like white
supremacist look at what the media has
done with a term like white supremacist
that term does mean something or at
least it should and there are actual
white supremacist out there I know
because I've I have I have the hate mail
from these people I know that they're
there I don't know how many people have
many of them are I think I think that
they are a fringe I'm certain they're a
fringe group but they do exist but when
you call everybody a white supremacist
when that term comes to mean just you
know people I don't like
then the leap label has lost its purpose
and its meaning and that becomes very
difficult when it's when it comes time
to talk about actual white supremacist
see when you call everyone a white
supremacist then what are you gonna say
when you actually encounter a real white
supremacist well you're gonna call them
a white supremacist but nobody knows
anymore so we're at a point now where if
someone calls someone else a white
supremacist the rest of us that are
hearing this we have no idea what that
means
we show
know what it means you know if you go
and say such and such as white
supremacists everyone that hears you
should know okay well I know what I need
to know about that person but we don't
know anymore
okay um you know it could mean that the
person you're referring to is an actual
racist who believes in these supremacy
of the white race sort of white
supremacist is and so you could be
telling us that that's you know that
that describes the person you're you're
talking about or but you could also
simply be saying you don't like the
person even though the person has never
said anything remotely racist you just
don't like them and so this is what
you're saying and and we don't know is
the problem could go either way which I
don't think I have to spell this out but
what happens is it provides cover to
actual racists and white supremacists
you have you have lumped them in with
millions of people who are not racist
and white supremacists and so they're
able to kind of hide you know they're
they become you have turned them into a
sort of needle at a haystack
when it does it shouldn't be that way it
doesn't need to be that way now it gets
better because after people like myself
and Ben and Michael pointed out all of
this to the Boston Globe they issued a
correction the next day and the
correction says because of a reporting
error the large column in today's arts
section which is printed in advance
mischaracterizes the conservative media
outlet The Daily wire its founder Ben
Shapiro has spoken out against the old
write the globe regrets the air now a
couple of problems with this correction
first of all it wasn't a reporting error
that makes it sound like oh it's silly
us we didn't mean that's not sorry just
kind of a typo but no that was a
deliberate intentional lie and a smear
that's what that was it wasn't a
reporting error it was a deliberate it
was it was a smears what it was
and also Ben Shapiro spoken out against
the alright that Weiwei understates it
Ben Shapiro has dedicated much of his
time to going after the all right just
like everyone else that the site has
done as well so in other states but the
the the real problem is they say they
regret the error okay what did they do
about the article did they take it down
no well did they at least chain delete
the smear against the Daily wire and
take out that whole part no they didn't
do that instead they they went back and
they changed it and instead of saying
white supremacists alt right outpost
now it says routinely bigoted outpost of
course we're back to the same problem
they didn't provide any evidence of that
they didn't provide any examples of
anything that any of us have said that's
bigoted they just throw it out there but
the thing that I like about this and you
know you can kind of laugh about it
because no one takes the Boston Globe
seriously anyway but the thing that I
like about it is you you can see just
how meaningless these labels are when
they're used by the media because we
could see in real time as they're just
cycling through one label after the
other they put one label on and everyone
says oh that's not right and then and
then the Boston Business
okay well we'll go with this one instead
then yeah I know that's not your okay
well how about this one they've got this
just carousel of slurs this carousel of
of labels that they'll you know they're
gonna rotate they're gonna put they're
gonna put one on you it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter if it's accurate or
not they're just gonna put it there you
take issue with one they'll just replace
it with something else
it's like mad libs
just absolute an absolute joke is what
it is okay
this was kind of funny by the way here's
a video from the Sanders campaign its
Alexandria Kaiser Cortez talking about
Bernie Sanders in very glowing terms a
man by the name of Bernie Sanders no no
okay
wait a second you didn't think you had
inherent value as a human being until
you heard Bernie Sanders really that is
that is the saddest thing I've ever
heard
IIIi really might start weeping over it
that's I I mean I was at the gas station
a few days ago and I saw someone in the
back of the gas station playing a slot
machine video game
and I thought that was the saddest thing
I'd ever seen until I solve this video
because this might actually beat it
listen if you're alerting anything at
all about life or yourself from a
politician that that's a very bad sign
and it also makes me question your
fitness for office a OC is a member of
Congress but she only discovered that
she's human when she heard Bernie
Sanders well win was that I think we
think it's a fair question
now granted Sanders has been in office
since the First Continental Congress so
who knows when she first heard Bernie
Sanders speak but I'm wondering when it
was that AOC had this Bernie induced
revelation I think we need to know that
also
what did she
think before she heard Bernie Sanders
did she think that she had no value as a
person so she thought she had no value
as a person she heard she she turned on
the TV saw Bernie Sanders waving his
hands wildly and screaming about
millionaires and billionaires and that's
when she had this Eureka moment and said
oh wow I think I do have value that's
very very strange and very sad and it's
also this cult of personality I talked
about all the time this cult of
personality around politicians it's
always sad and pathetic and unamerican
and you don't just see it on the Left
there's a cult of personality around
Donald Trump
you got a cult of personality around
Bernie Sanders there's a cult of
personality around
Alexandr okay CEO Cortes herself so she
you know she's in the Bernie Sanders
cult but she's got her own sort of
splinter cult going on all of this is is
just way off base okay politicians are
politicians they're not they're not
spiritual gurus they're not prophets you
know they're also not rock stars that
were that we should be fans of they're
politicians their representatives
supposedly of the people they are
supposedly our employees they work for
us that that's the way it's supposed to
be and I think we would do very well to
keep that in mind with how we look at
these people and and talk about them
okay now um let's see before I get to
emails I wanted to talk about this also
and I don't mean to pick on this person
I don't know who she is and and it
doesn't matter the person is not the
point it's just the sentiment that I
wanted to talk about so someone on
Twitter posted something that I only saw
because it was rude retweet at a bunch
of times and what the tweet says is you
all really want to get married and have
sex with the same person for the rest of
your life question mark question mark
question mark all caps and for some
reason this got like ten thousand ten
thousand likes people it resonates I'm
just using this as a jumping-off point
but
this is well there's a reason why it's
was a popular tweet that this is a very
common objection that you hear all the
time and anecdotally it seems to me that
it's an increasingly popular argument
against marriage though of course it's
not at all new but this is something
people have been saying for a long time
so I've been thinking about this after I
saw this tweet and I I wanted to say
something to anyone in the audience who
might share this point of view about
marriage you know I don't want to have
sex with the same person for the rest of
my life that kind of thing a few things
about that first of all yes if you want
to consider marriage in the most
pessimistic possible way if you want to
take the most negative view of it that
you could you might say that marriage
means being stuck with the same person
forever not just sexually but in all
things and life in general fine yeah you
could you could look at it that way if
you want to but what's the most
pessimistic possible way of considering
the alternative I know as a as a
dyed-in-the-wool pessimist myself I have
no problem I think I think it's a good a
good idea before you make any particular
big decision you should think to
yourself what is the worst possible way
that I could think of this thing maybe
that's not the bit maybe that's not the
healthiest way to make life choices but
as a pessimist that's what you do it's
sort another way of putting is like
what's the worst-case scenario here you
have to at least consider that right
well the alternative what's the
worst-case scenario what's the what's
the most negative view of that someone
who's concerned about having sex with
the same person for the rest of life and
so therefore avoids marriage what's the
negative view of that choice well the
negative view is that you're gonna end
up having a series of meaningless
encounters with strangers who don't love
you or care about you until eventually
you get too old for that and you don't
have the same looks that you did when
you were younger and you're not
desirable in the same way that you were
before to strangers and now all of your
peers are spending their free time going
to the playground with their
grandchildren while you're alone and
pitied by everyone
and then you die and there's no one to
mourn you and you leave no legacy behind
or even any trace that you ever existed
at all so I guess you have to decide
between those two options which one
sounds worse and another thing and I've
noticed it I was thinking about this
this morning
because it's kind of strange when I talk
to people who don't want to get married
the first thing they often say is is
something like this about how they don't
want to have sex with the same person or
you know they just they don't to be
stuck with the same person for their
whole life and all that but and they're
concerned about how tedious and boring
and monotonous that will be but then the
next thing they say or the second most
common objection to marriage that I hear
is that after you get married you never
know how much the other person is going
to change or in what way they might
change and so it's too much of a risk to
tie yourself to them so you notice the
paradox here I I'm sure on one hand
they're worried that there won't be any
change and on the other hand they're
worried that there will be too much
change on one hand marriage is too safe
and too boring on the other hand it's
too much of a risk so you see the how
those two things don't quite match up
now again if you're committed to the
pessimistic interpretation you might say
that well that's because marriage is the
worst of both worlds but I don't think
that's true I think that these two
competing objections just speak to the
fact that marriage is first of all
dynamic and unpredictable and and and
very human you know as two human beings
involved in this thing and on the
positive and the point is that yes
you're committing yourself to one person
but a person is a fascinating and
compelling thing I think a person is way
more interesting than people so when
you're just out doing the random hookup
thing all you have our people you have
this
kind of general vague collective mass
and you're working your way through the
crowd
everyone is faceless everyone is
basically nameless you forget about them
in two days that's that's people but in
a marriage you get a person not people
you get a person a real living breathing
human person somebody with a name and a
face and a personality and hopes and
dreams and goals and flaws and foibles
and virtues and strengths and weaknesses
and pet peeves and idiosyncrasies and
all of it you get all of that and you're
with that person as they grow and change
and develop and maybe not all the
changes are favorable from your point of
view and obviously sometimes things will
go horribly wrong and everything falls
apart but no matter what your life
choice is things can always go horribly
wrong and fall apart so you know that's
that's no different the goal though of
marriage is to be with this person and
to grow alongside them and I think that
that can be a very exciting thing so
where if you're looking for the
pessimistic view you say it's the worst
of both worlds another way of looking at
it is it's the best best of both worlds
where you do get the change and the
differences and the variety but you get
it with one person so at the same time
you get that commitment and the love and
the you know the experience of being
really known by another human being
which i think is an experience that we
all deeply need you know III guess as
human beings we could never be
completely known by anyone on earth
because they can't read our minds but in
marriage you can you know not just in a
physical sense but you can intimately
know another person and that's what you
get of from marriage along with the
variety of the fact that the person does
change and grow and everything else and
this is I also say this about I say this
all the time when we talk about should
you get married younger or not and you
know I I understand the logic of waiting
until
and you're more established in life and
all that kind of stuff
and if you're already a little bit older
and you haven't gotten married yet then
that's fine you could still get married
and have a wonderful marriage but if you
are younger and you're trying to decide
I think there's a lot to be said for
getting married younger because this is
what I'm talking about you grow and live
alongside the other person where
marriage rather than being the capstone
of adulthood it's the it's the
cornerstone it's the foundation and you
build from there and you're with this
person and you're both growing and
maturing so you know I got married when
I was 25 my wife was 24 obviously when
we got married we didn't have kids we
were just you know as far as I'm
concerned we were basically kids
ourselves so on one hand I could say yes
I've been married to the same person for
eight years but you know especially when
you get married younger it's it it
typically is the same person but but we
we've changed so much through the
process of growing and living that it's
that you know it kind of can be
deceptive to put it that way so just
just something to consider I think
marriage is great marriage and family
maybe not you know not not every life
choice is for everybody there are
exceptions of course and there are
people who are called to different ways
of living but I think there are a lot of
people who are called to marriage but
don't do it because they're afraid for
these two reasons or other reasons as
well and I think that's a big mistake
all right going to emails Matt Walsh Oh
at gmail.com
Matt well show at gmail.com this is from
Colin says future supreme overlord I am
bothered by how soon Christmas
commercials are being played as soon as
Halloween at Halloween is over the
Christmas commercials start playing is
it not more reasonable to begin
commercials after Thanksgiving or
December first as dictator will you
enforce a limitation on when Christmas
commercials can begin playing your
humble servant and soon-to-be executed
subject home no in fact if anything I'll
go the other way
and certainly the harsh penalties will
not go to the stores that play Christmas
music early or people who put up
Christmas lights early know the harsh
penalty goes to the people the
unamerican joy hating people who
complain about that I am a big believer
in look I mean if you want to start
playing the Christmas music in July go
ahead hukum I don't even I don't
understand the complaint you hear
Christmas music when you're out shopping
and it's not December yet and you get
angry about it now I get angry about a
lot of things I basically get angry
professionally it's basically my job and
even I can't figure out how to get angry
about that I cannot figure out how to
get angry when I hear hark the herald
angels sing how could you get mad about
that I don't even understand it so
anytime I hear Christmas music even as a
Scrooge myself it warms my heart it
warms my cold dead heart and and I feel
I feel something approaching joy and it
doesn't matter what time of year it is
so I you know what just Colin how dare
you from mark this says hi Matt I can't
stand all these people that rejoice over
their extra hour of sleep they obviously
don't have young children the end of
daylight savings time means parents have
an extra hour of parenting then to get
your kids back on a normal schedule you
keep them up until their normal bedtime
and the final hours full of meltdowns
once your rule commences will you end
daylight saving times and abolish all
the gloating well rested jerks thanks
for the great show prayers for you and
your family yes this is this is
something I and I had this experience
every year I think all parents do and I
had it on Saturday where I thought oh
you know it's daily saving times I get
an extra hour of sleep and then you look
around and see all the kids running
around your house and you remember that
oh yeah I'm a parent never mind all this
means is that rather than my kids being
up at 6:00 a.m. now they're gonna be up
at 5:00 a.m. that's that's all this
means
now as dictator of course I first of all
I can force people to get up with my
kids and watch them so that would be my
first move I don't
have to worry about that as a dictator
and and I would certainly have people
you know I would have people taking care
of the kids in the morning and at night
and overnight and during the day and my
job is just to pop in every once in a
while you know that's real parent thing
for you that's how you really parent as
far as daylight savings time you know
taking the parent issue aside this is
another thing people complain about
daylight savings time just like they
complain about Christmas music too early
I don't with the daily saving times
except for the parent complain which is
a legitimate complaint aside from that I
don't really understand the problem with
it I kind of like it and in fact the
fact that it's so weird and pointless
and arbitrary that we just arbitrarily
pretend to move the time forward and
back I kind of like it imagine aliens
landing on earth sometime in the future
and finding out about daylight savings
time and us trying to explain it to them
where we say that oh yeah it's just you
know we pretend that the clock is we
just we move that we move the time time
back and forth randomly just because and
they would have absolutely no idea the
point of that or why we do it
and we have no idea why we do it either
but we just do it and that's what I like
about it's kind of quirky and weird and
it's just something we do and I say I'm
a traditionalist and I believe in you
know just sticking with the tradition
for no reason that's why I like it from
david says hello Matt hope all is well
and that the new baby is doing great
yesterday you were talking about the
topic of criminalization of assisted
suicide I believe the government
shouldn't criminalize it because that
would allow them the option to remove
freedom from people because the
government deems it to be for the good
of the person which then which then
allows the government to also do it for
other actions they don't want people
doing because the government sees us as
not is it not being for their good that
doesn't mean I don't think doctors and
others shouldn't try to help these
people to go on living but said help
should not be forced on these people nor
should that remove their freedom the
government will always be able to
justify any removal of right as being
for the good of the person so I side
with people
keeping their freedom even if I don't
even if even if it's not for their own
good
we shouldn't encourage suicidal people
but if they do decide they don't want to
help they don't want help at that point
they should be able to seek the end they
want unfortunate as it is if people
decide so that what worries me is the
government deciding for them and
arbitrarily removing their rights in the
process would you trust the government
to know better for the person than the
person for themselves does for
themselves and allow the government to
the power to remove the rights of the
person as such well first of all okay a
couple things here as far as knowing you
know knowing better for the bird knowing
what's best for the person or having a
better idea of what's what's good for a
person than they do themselves you know
if if you were walking down the road and
you looked up and saw someone standing
at the edge of a building like they're
about to jump I'm sure you would shout
to them and say no don't do it and you
would try to stop them right you would
never say wow he probably knows what's
best for him and just keep walking so in
in some situations it actually is clear
that someone doesn't know what's best
for them and they do need someone to
step in and kind of force the issue
force them to do what's best with it can
never be best for you to jump off a
building or to intentionally poison
yourself that could never be the best
thing for you how could it be because
it's you're abolishing yourself you're
getting rid of your it's it's the end of
yourself
how could ending yourself be the best
for yourself it doesn't even make any
sense
so and and I think on a it so now let's
you could say well that's okay but these
are I'm a free I'm an individual person
and this is a you know I'm not an agent
of the government okay well you see the
person standing on the edge of the
building they're gonna jump do you call
the police I think
you're decent compassionate person you
call the police I would well the police
are agents of the government and what do
you want the police to do you want the
police to stop them from jumping if a
police officer in fact I saw there was a
video that was making the rounds on
online a few months ago this happens he
of a someone that was about to jump off
a bridge might've been the Golden Gate
Bridge I don't know somebody by the jump
off a bridge and a police officer
stopped his car ran up and grabbed the
person to last minute and dragged him
back from from the edge and everyone is
hailing this police officer as a hero
for good reason I think he is a hero but
would you say that that police officer
did the wrong thing you know this was a
person making a choice for themselves
here was an agent of the state
preventing them from making that choice
I the interesting thing to me is that it
seems like almost everybody would agree
that the police officer did the right
thing yet many of those people who agree
the police officers do the right thing
still think that assisted suicide should
be legal on the basis that the
government shouldn't prevent people from
killing themselves so it just it there's
you see the disconnect there if you if
you think it would be cruel and and
negligent in the extreme for the police
officer just sit back and watch the guy
jump if you think that would be cruel
and negligent then how is it not also
cruel and negligent for the government
to not just allow people to kill
themselves but to legalize a a method
for which they can go through to kill
themselves I just I don't see it seems
to me that if one you know if the state
is right in the one hand then they'd be
right on the other hand of you know
making assisted suicide illegal so that
that's the first thing second thing
assisted suicide we're talking about
assisted suicide we're not talking about
someone just taking their own life as
the saying goes you know the there might
there are some states maybe where it's
technically illegal to commit suicide
but of course the you know the reality
there is if someone succeeds in doing it
then it's the light of the law was sort
of a moot point and of course if
somebody really wants to commit suicide
if they really want to there's nothing
the state can do to stop them it's short
of if you know about it ahead of time
and they're you know putting a admitted
into a psychiatric facility or something
like that
short of that there's nothing that the
state can do but what we're talking
about here is getting a third party
involved so it's not really a question
of should a person have the right to
kill themselves it's should the third
party have a right to help kill someone
and to that I would say no so I'm
it's on two levels here on one level I
do think the state has a role in
preventing people from killing
themselves and as I already described I
think you probably agree at least in
some circumstances and if you agree in
some circumstances then why not in every
circumstance but we can even put that
argument to the side because that's not
even really what we're talking about
here we're talking about a third party
coming in and it just so happens to be a
doctor it happens to be a representative
of the medical community coming in and
poisoning someone so you don't even have
to think of it as does this individual
have the right to kill themselves the
question is does that doctor have the
right to go and poison somebody whether
they want it or not and my thing is that
they should not have that third party
should not have that right it should be
illegal for a doctor to intentionally
and directly kill someone and I think
that should be the law and I think that
there's really no downside to that
there's no downside to I should say
there's no downside to a law that says
it's illegal for a doctor to
intentionally directly kill someone I
think there are a lot of downsides to
opening that door and saying well maybe
sometimes they can and you know I I
don't think I need to describe where the
slippery slope leads and we're already
seeing the slippery slope when doctors
get into the business of killing what is
the slippery slope if we just said
doctors can't kill people what's the
slippery slope scenario for that what's
what's the dystopian vision of a world
where no doctors are killing people I
just seen absolutely no downside to that
whereas there is nothing but downside to
the alternative
okay but thank you for the email and
thanks everybody for else for watching
and listening
Godspeed Matt Walsh show is produced by
Robert Sterling associate producer
alexia Garcia Del Rio executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show the Democrats are
beginning to wake up to the fact that
their candidates stink and their
impeachment nonsense is going nowhere
it's as if the entire Democrat Party
woke up naked in Times Square I'll try
to get that image out of our heads on
the Andrew Klavan show on Andrew Clayton